[Musique]
il est 20h et les deux candidats qui
sont qualifiés pour le second tour de la
présidentielle sont Emmanuel Macron et
Marine Le Pen Jean-Luc Mélenchon
20,1% et puis très loin après
Eric Zemmour 7,2% la candidate des
républicains Valérie Pécresse 5 Yannick
Jadot l'écologie 4,4
5% c'est un plus bas historique pour les
républicains et Yannick Jadot pourrait
même être devant Valérie Pécresse et
bien sûr plus qu'une douche froide c'est
un cataclysme pour ce parti qui est
désormais va devoir se reconstruire déjà
si on arrive à sourire sourire de
soi-même de ses exagérations de ces
scénarios catastrophes c'est déjà pas
mal après coup rire souvent dans la vie
des gens effectivement c'est excellent
alors on suppose que ça peut-être
peut-être un effet prolongé ça nous
permet au stress suivant de stresser
moins fort mais en tout cas globalement
le rire est bon pour la santé Jean
Lassalle 3,3 Fabien Roussel pour le
parti communiste 2,7 Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan 2,3 devant le Parti
socialiste Anne Hidalgo ce soir vous
n'imaginez pas que le Parti socialiste
pourrait faire encore moins qu'en 2017
avec
6,39% là vous êtes à deux pour cent
c'est un séisme économique pour vous
c'est une déception politique majeure
bien évidemment mais ce que je retiens
c'est que pour la deuxième fois
consécutive la gauche est éliminée du
second tour de l'élection essentielle
dans la 5e République
du point échec qui mate refaire
de la médaille
mais ce que je veux dire je vais quand
je vous interrompre parce qu'on va
écouter et je vous donnerai la parole
juste derrière on va écouter Yannick
Jadot qui s'exprime
merci pour ou contre le droit de vote à
16 ans alors là je les garde pour voter
en France et 18 ans là je minimum bien
sûr et à l'approche du premier tour des
élections présidentielles et se pose
cette question notamment pour pallier
peut-être au taux d'abstinence records
[Applaudissements]
on vient d'écouter Yannick Jadot je
voudrais juste une réaction parce que je
voyais non mais j'ai fait la tête je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la balle est dans
le camp d'Emmanuel Macron qu'en est-il
des intentions de vote des profs cette
année je vous montre tout de suite la
projection qui est faite pour le premier
tour et c'est amusant sur cnews
l'extrême gauche s'appelle l'extrême
gauche mais l'extrême droite s'appelle
la droite nationale on s'est tout de
suite plus choupi c'est moins effrayant
là de droite nationale ça sonne plus
douillet et accessoirement leur sondage
donne un total de 138% et si on peut
revoir juste un dernier image le 47 est
plus petit que le 28 enfin voilà et
c'est au nord de la part de cnews non
l'orange je vous donnerai la parole
juste après Rachida Dati je vous le
promets mais Laurent je crois que vous
vouliez nous emmener dans un QG et vous
étiez fait pour être bouché fils de
boucher
famille boucher et
il y avait les voyous d'un côté avec la
famille Zemmour le gang des postiches et
de l'autre côté il y avait des années
et aujourd'hui
de ce résultat merci que nous avons
construit de nos marques et quand tu
fasses le show parce que si tu prends le
journaliste qui qui qui dit les
questions comme il annonce une nouvelle
comme ça c'est toute la vie la
différence entre un journaliste c'est un
animateur faut que tu fasses le show que
tu mettes l'ambiance tu as tout en
faisant les choses sérieusement c'est ça
bien sûr
j'essayais de faire pendant une
trentaine d'années j'ai la verse pas les
responsabilités vous devriez aussi en
tirer aussi les conséquences y compris
dans votre partie
on artiste pas à 2% on ne parle pas à
une partie de la population et je pense
que c'est un des sujets de la
présidentielle en même temps sinon on
entend rien